how do you end up with people that do
this type of thing how do you end up
with these you know
childhood Shooters how do you end up
with people that go into a school
and do this and I think a lot of it is
to me a lot of it is a societal thing
and I'm not gonna everybody has their
views I'm not challenging your view here
this is just a space where I'm sharing
what I think and I could be wrong
that's totally okay
but I I feel and I think sometimes that
people don't have purpose
you have a country where
you know it used to feel like like if
you worked at a I mean I'm gonna go off
on some different thoughts here so if
you worked at like a business then
you had a lot of middle class businesses
you had a small a lot of smaller
businesses and if you work there then if
the company did well you did well and so
you had a sense of purpose maybe through
your work you know you're going to move
up the ladder you were going to be
um you know a foreman and then a a a
manager and then maybe have some
percentage share and then you know
you're going to get to a place
and now it feels I think like we've
we've let a lot of our companies get to
these big conglomerates and
it's about the bottom line
a lot of companies are holding to their
shareholders but not to their
share croppers if you will to the people
working within the company
um
so then what I'm saying is as a person
you may not feel any people you I feel
like you people can get a sense of
purpose from their work
so if you don't have that sense of
purpose then
then you can be pretty aimless right and
then if you don't have love like if
somebody doesn't love you or you feel
unloved or you don't love somebody like
if you don't have a um family
or a husband or wife or children
then you may not feel like a lot of love
right and so having love gives you a
sense of purpose
so and we have less families these days
the familial structure is really kind of
broken down in America
you know you have a lot of single parent
homes you have a lot of two parents
having to work
um
so right there we're kind of
right there there's a place where people
where I feel like people used to get a
lot of purpose
and now
a lot of there's people that aren't
getting purpose from their work and
there's people that aren't getting
purpose from
uh their heart being fulfilled
by someone else or them being the piece
that fills someone else's heart
so right there man you have a lot you
have people who don't have a lot of
purpose
um
and then there used to be a sense of
America we are this country we are these
people we are united we are
we care about our neighbor
um
but that's a lot of that has gone by the
wayside uh
uh we've become a
you know I feel like our our
political leaders have sold us
out to the highest bidder I feel like
it feels like um
it doesn't feel any more like your
politicians or your leaders have your
best interest it doesn't feel that way
uh
and I'm not crying here I'm just trying
to I'm trying to see how do we get to
somebody that does something like that
that's what I've been thinking about
like how do you get there how do you get
to somebody that does a um shooting of a
school
you know
um
because you got to get there somehow
and it keeps happening
so anyway I think that a lot of it is
purpose if you don't have a purpose then
you are at the whim of whatever could
come along
you're at the whim of whatever influence
you whatever influence you get or
whatever ideology comes along they
um
that you can attach onto
and
so no job no love no real sense of Honor
or connection to your country
so then you I mean you're
and then on top of that if you if you
find that you're the victim if you start
to say well I'm a victim
you know it's my you know everybody else
I don't have any responsibility for
myself it's all your fault it's all your
fault
then you're going to find not only are
you going to find any ideology that
comes along which the internet is going
to give the internet it creates an
algorithm that gives you whatever you
keep looking at you get more of
so if you look at pudding or something
you get all pudding boy
and then three years from now I'm
wondering why you two thick you can't be
in the military now because buddy you
putting doubt you chose pudding and
pudding chose you
because whatever Vice it is it'll choose
you back so you so if you if you want to
be someone who
um is
you know you want to get involved with
us like a alt-right or alt left or you
want to get involved with
um
School shooters or uh anti-christian or
anti-um
I'm just trying to think something some
severe ideology you want to get then the
internet the Twitter whatever is going
to keep serving you it
so now you next thing you know you're
down a rabbit hole
and I think at that point
that's how you end up there I think
you end up in a place where I'm gonna
I'm gonna be seen I'm gonna make sure
they know who I am
I'm going to make sure that they say my
name or they hear my name or they see me
um
and that's just it's a that's
heartbreaking along the whole way
you know so I don't know I think I've
just been having a lot of thoughts about
that how do people end up there
how do people get to a place where they
would do that sort of thing now some
people I think are just crazy
and those are
um
crazy people that's different
but how does someone who's just been you
know
because next thing you know you're on
Twitter you get an anti-religious thing
you're like oh I went to a religious
school I also have trouble identifying
in the world maybe sexually so
man I'm evict it's all
man you really
and then your Twitter your feed your
social media just keeps serving you more
of that hey you're right you're right
you're right
and then man you're gassed up
um
so I think a lot of it is a sense of
purpose you know
[Music]
and having a sense of purpose
and some of those sense of purposes like
the American when I can feel I felt like
when I was a child it felt like oh we're
part of this you know
but
it doesn't feel like that a lot anymore
but also I got to recognize that I can
still do things to try and make myself
have a purpose
you know uh
and you find purpose and you know I'm
fortunate that people love me my family
you know
um
you know that I have a job I have this
podcast to come to I have uh
I have some sense of purpose for myself
you know
and a lot of you guys do too I think
we're kind of a purpose-filled group or
we're trying to find that but I think
that's something that um
I feel like that's for me that's
something I think that that that's part
of that
is that man when you don't have a
purpose
the dark arts well they were they are
they are at your door they are waiting
on the edge of your ear to come in and
get your brain
and those include like you know all the
just the links just the rabbit hole you
can go down and it'll make you hate
because man you find a rabbit hole
you can when you get halfway to the
bottom of that there's a HOA
meeting of just hateful Owners
Association
halfway through some of these rabbit
holes and it's just
it's just dangerous so
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one